tf1 à 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
sénatoriales les principaux résultats
dans un instant une première
constatation légère poussée de la gauche
après le film édition spéciale tf1 sur
ces élections françois mitterrand en
haute-loire la ligne marché ne fera pas
changer les socialistes georges marchais
au club de la presse si les socialistes
respecte l'accord de 1972 on peut signer
dans les 24 heures
lucie fort les pousses du président de
l'assemblée nationale est décédé cet
après midi victime d'une crise cardiaque
cyclisme/tour versailles où tu mêles
quand l'ex l'épreuve le premier français
dans guillaume est 5e madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
c'était aujourd'hui en france les
élections sénatoriales
dès notre édition de 13 heures puis dans
une courte édition spéciale cet après
midi nous vous avons tenu au courant des
derniers résultats
je vous rappelle qu'il s'agissait de
renouveler le mandat de 115 sénateurs
qui ont été lus par plus de 43000 grands
électeurs c'est à dire députés et
conseillers généraux et surtout délégués
des conseils municipaux
tf1 est maintenant en mesure de vous
donner les résultats définitifs de ces
élections sénatoriales avec jacques
hébert d'abord la liste des
personnalités élues ou bête oui je vous
rappelle d'abord qu'en cette période de
politique plutôt mouvante et bien il est
bon d'être élu pour neuf ans en sachant
qu on ne dissout pas laisser à ceux ci
expliquent à renouvellement important au
niveau des hommes du sénat avec de
nombreuses vedettes politiques entre
guillemets candidats de cette fois ci il
y avait quatre ministres et 17 députés
alors on se référant à notre tableau des
personnalités voici donc quelques
résultats sont d'abord personnalités
élus ou réélus georges dayan socialiste
ami de françois mitterrand à paris
jean-pierre fourcade république un
ministre de l'équipement dans les
hauts-de-seine jean pierre fourcade
ayant déjà dit qu'il quitterait le
gouvernement s'il était élu sénateur
un remaniement ministériel est donc à
prévoir dans les semaines qui viennent
marie thérèse guthmann communiste élu
dans la seine saint denis jean lecanuet
et centristes maire de rouen dans la
seine maritime
max lejeune centriste président du
groupe réformateur à l'assemblée
nationale max lejeune qui donc son siège
de député ce siège restera vacant
jusqu'aux prochaines législatives
christian de la malène rpr premier
adjoint du maire de paris jacques chirac
rené monory centriste ministre de
l'industrie du commerce et de
l'artisanat dans la vienne il a fait
savoir lui qu'il ne quitterait pas le
gouvernement
c'est donc son suppléant guy robert qui
occupera le siège alain poher centriste
président du sénat élu dans le
val-de-marne christian poncelet rpr
secrétaire d'état aux relations avec le
parlement dans les vosges
robert pantillon socialiste maire de
suresnes dans les hauts-de-seine
enfin pierre christian taittinger
républicain secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères un par d'autres
personnalités élus ou réélus francisque
collomb maire de lyon louis longequeue
maire de limoges
brigitte groupe qui est la soeur de jjss
dans les yvelines
guichard aux communistes dans les
hauts-de-seine roger romani rpr à paris
jean chamant républicain ancien ministre
dans l'yonne
quelques personnalités battu à présent
jacques maroselli vice président des
radicaux de gauche dans la haute-saône
robert parenti sénateur centriste
sortant dans les hauts-de-seine
louis delmas maire socialiste de
montauban et enfin jambaque rpr sénateur
sortant des hiboux bien voici donc pour
les personnalités élues réélu ou battus
mais avec vous patrice duhamel nous
allons analyser les faits marquants de
ces élections sénatoriales et bien
le fait marquant si vous voulez on s'y
attendait un petit peu c'est d'une
manière générale la c'est grande
stabilité politique de ce renouvellement
du tiers de ceux du sénat ce n'est pas
une surprise c'est ce que l'on prévoyait
et c'est ce que l'on vous avez dit
depuis plusieurs jours la poussée de la
gauche est en effet extrêmement légère
elle est le résultat presque automatique
des dernières élections cantonales de
1976 et des dernières élections
municipales de 1977 une poussée de la
gauche qu'il est encore difficile de
chiffrer très exactement parce que nous
n'avons pas en réalité tous les
résultats définitifs mais il semble qu
environ une quinzaine de sièges nouveaux
vont être gagné par soit les socialistes
soient les communistes soient les
radicaux de gauche le fait marquant
c'est que c'est dans les nouveaux sièges
ce qui avait été créé pour tenir compte
de la poussée démographique dans un
certain nombre de départements c'est
dans ces nouveaux sièges sur tout et
empereur en priorité que la gauche
remporte un certain nombre de sièges
c'est le cas dans les départements du
rhône de la seine maritime de la seine
saint denis des yvelines de l'essonne du
val d'oise et du val de marne danse les
départements où l'on crée de nouveaux
sièges la majorité a remporté l 3 sièges
en vendée en seine-et-marne et en haute
savoie il faut noter également qu'à
paris où on n'avait pas augmenté le
nombre de sièges est bien la majorité a
gagné un siège et là maintenant huit
élus et ce siège
elle l'a gagnée sur le parti communiste
il ya pour terminer dernier fait
marquant deux départements où la
tendance a été ou l'equilibre a été
renversé c'est d'abord l'essonne dans la
région parisienne c'est là le résultat
direct automatique des élections
municipales de mars dernier
c'est ensuite les yvelines où il ya
maintenant trois sénateurs de
l'opposition et deux sénateurs de la
majorité
là c'est peut-être c'est sans doute la
conséquence de la division de la
majorité
il y avait en effet deux listes de la
majorité et une seule liste de
l'opposition voilà ce qu'on peut dire
avant d'avoir je vous le rappelle tous
les résultats définitifs nous les aurons
bien entendu à 22h15 bien sûr ce plateau
spécial de tf1 avec nous alain lancelot
spécialiste de sciences politiques
vous avez étudié tout cet après midi
dans le détail les résultats qu'ils
parvenaient la rédaction de tf1
est ce que votre avis les dernières
élections municipales et surtout la
cassure de la gauche ont une influence
en ce qui concerne l' influence de la
rue pts
ur de la gauche elle ne peut être que
très faible sur l'élection d'aujourd'hui
puisque ces élections ont été très
largement joué avant cette rupture ils
ont été joués en réalité le 4 septembre
lorsque ont été élus les délégués
sénatoriaux ceux qui aujourd'hui se sont
rendus aux urnes
la seule influence possible de de la
rupture de la gauche elle pourrait être
décelées dans les deux tours dans les
rapports entre les deux tours mais nous
avons encore que quelques résultats de
second tour nous allons scruter ses
résultats au microscope jusqu'à notre
édition spéciale pour voir s'il ya eu un
effet mais a priori est difficile de le
type en revanche jean claude bourret les
élections municipales ont nécessairement
joué un rôle décisif car les électeurs
qui ont voté aujourd'hui proviennent à
raison de 90 7 % des délégués désignés
par les conseils municipaux
ce sont donc les hommes qui ont été élus
en mars dernier qui pèse totalement dans
le scrutin d'aujourd'hui
ces élections dans une certaine mesure
elle noël ont été joués le 4 septembre
elles ont été aussi joué en mars dernier
c'est là qu'il faut chercher la source
des deux traits qu'on observe
aujourd'hui la grande stabilité dans la
france rurale et la petite poussée à
gauche dans la france urbaine
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on éclaire
un peu surpris de voir que contrairement
à ce qu'ont observé au lendemain des
municipales
ça ne pas l'impression d'une grande
poussée de gauche mais parce que vous au
lendemain des municipales on était
polarisé sur la france urbaine où le jeu
du scrutin majoritaire avait amplifié le
mouvement aujourd'hui dans la france
urbaine c'est la proportionnelle qui
joue et c'est un scrutin brise lames à
cet égard est là elle amplifie mois les
mouvements en sièges que le scrutin
majoritaire
fabrizzio mail oui je crois que l'on
peut dire pour terminer pour les
premiers enseignements que de toute
manière est bien évidemment la majorité
actuelle qui soutient le président de la
république garde
regardez largement la majorité c'était
un petit peu plus des deux tiers dans le
dernier sénat ce sera sans doute
vraisemblablement à partir de ce soir
lorsque tous les résultats sont connus
un tout petit peu moins des deux tiers
de majorité donc au sénat un an
précisément au sénat ce soir règne
agitation inhabituelle pour un dimanche
soir en direct du sénat nous retrouvons
alain ferme bac pour les premières
réactions
oui l'agitation habituelle n'osait le
sait le sénat c'est toujours un club
c'est par l'assemblée nationale c'est
plutôt un club anglais
eh bien vous parliez tout à l'heure de
microscopes et bien déjà ici au sénat on
se penche sur le microscope pour
analyser les chiffres et il ya un détail
s'il se confirme qui sera peut-être très
important en effet dans le val de marne
dans l'essonne et à paris sans qui un
changement de tendance
on note un glissement des voix
socialistes verts les communistes et
quand on sait que dans ces trois
départements le parti socialiste la
majorité et appartient aux crs c'est
intéressant après les événements de la
semaine passée ce qui prouverait que le
crs a préféré au cours de ces
sénatoriales un rapprochement avec le
parti communiste mais n'anticipons pas
encore une fois il faudra analyser les
résultats de très près vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure les quatre membres du
gouvernement ont été élus ou réélus
membres du sénat mais trois déjà ou
annoncé qu'il démissionnerait des
gouvernements un seul ne veut pas de ce
que vous avez appelé tout à l'heure le
bail de neuf ans le bail de sécurité
c'est monsieur vous nourrit ministre
d'industrie
alors le sumo nourrit sénateurs ce matin
mais pour 24 heures car demain vous
laisserait la place à votre suppléant
pour rester ministre donc c'est en tant
que membre du gouvernement et ce au nom
du gouvernement que je vous demande
votre réaction politique alors c'est la
stabilité
eh bien c'est la stabilité c'est même
pour le groupe centriste du sénat auquel
j'appartiens une excellente surprise
puisque tous les pronostiqueurs au cours
ces dernières semaines laissé penser que
ce groupe seraient particulièrement
touchés parce que la poussée de
l'opposition avait été grande aux
municipales finalement sur 24 sortant
nous aurons vraisemblement un deux ou
trois rentrant supplémentaires ce qui
est une excellente surprise mais surtout
si on fait l'analyse politique
ce qui démontre à l'évidence que les
maires qui sont en général un électorat
disons modéré un écrin de réflexion est
tout à fait intéressé parce que nous
représentons
je crois que le centrisme au sénat est
un centrisme moderne un centriste je
dirais solidaire
un centre et de proposition et je crois
qu'il ya là matière à tirer des leçons
pour la majorité pour les élections
légistatives je pense que ce centre
gauche en quelque sorte aura encore
demain grand rôle à jouer
donc c'est un membre de gouvernement qui
met l'accent en ce moment sur le centre
gauche
est-ce qu'il faut voir là une
signification politique ou tout
simplement parce que vous êtes centriste
enfin ce n'est pas du tout une
signification politique c'est parce que
je crois profondément que au moment où
il apparaît quelques cracks hurou
quelques fissures du côté de la gauche
que la majorité doit au delà de l'accord
dont je me félicite être suffisamment
moderne pour proposer dans quelques mots
en français une société avec sans doute
un peu plus d'égalité un peu plus de
justice et surtout beaucoup de liberté
alors si on tire les enseignements de ce
scrutin favorable à ce que je représente
à ce que représente mes amis je pense
qu'il y a là une voie à rechercher qui
peut apporter sans doute des solutions
dans la liberté dans la justice bien
versé victorine nous retrouverons ici au
sénat 22h15 pour un débat et là vous
verrez qui s'il ya stabilité il ya aussi
rajeunissement
après ce renouvellement du tiers du
sénat
bien la ferme bac vous nous parliez à
l'instant donnant les résultats du crs
je crois qu'il n'est pas utile de
préciser que le crs celel gauche du
parti socialiste emmenée par jean pierre
chevènement
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
christian bonnet vient de commenter il
ya quelques minutes le résultat de ces
élections sénatoriales c'est donc le
premier commentaire politique du
gouvernement ministère de l'intérieur
nous allons prendre connaissance
immédiatement l'instabilité du corps
électoral sénatorial apparaît très
grande elle est plus grande
on ne l'imaginait généralement six mois
après le glissement constatés aux
élections municipales alors qu on
crédite est généralement l'opposition
d'une progression de quelques 20 sièges
7 en définitive une progression de
y siège qu'elles accusent imputable pour
neuf d'entre eux aux 12 sièges
créée en 1975 la majorité s'est
d'ailleurs présenté dans l'ensemble plus
unie à ce scrutin que ne le faisait
l'opposition et elle en a recueilli les
fruits
abstraction faite des six sièges à
pourvoir au titre des départements
d'outre-mer dont les résultats ne seront
connus que dans quelques heures la
composition politique de la nouvelle
assemblée se présentera comme suit
opposition 106 membres contre eux 96
majorité 189 contre eux 187
dans un cas un gain de 10 sièges pour
l'opposition
généralement crédité de 20 je le répète
ces jours derniers un gain de 2 sièges
pour la majorité qui conserve donc au
sénat une avance importante sur
l'opposition
le souci de rigueur qui inspire ce bref
commentaire nous interdit d'anticiper
sur le choix que feront les nouveaux
élus tant de l'opposition que de la
majorité du groupe auquel il se rattache
rond les prochains jours nous
apporterons à cet égard les linières
nécessaire voilà je vous donne
rendez-vous maintenant après le film de
votre dimanche soir pour l'édition
spéciale du service politique de tf1
concernant ces élections sénatoriales
ce week-end il ya eu encore beaucoup de
déclarations de personnalités
socialistes et communistes déclaration
qui continuent à renvoyer sur le
partenaire et avec vigueur
la responsabilité de l'échec au sommet
de la gauche à tel point que les mêmes
phrases un mot prix ont été prononcées
par une demi douzaine de personnalités
de la gauche communiste ou socialiste
mais ce soir ce sont à nouveau les
leaders qui ont pris la parole nous
allons les entendre successivement
d'abord françois mitterrand qui a parlé
cet après midi à brioude en haute loire
eh bien nous allons continuer un mot
d'ordre que le parti socialiste
grandisse un autre modèle qu'il soit le
garant de l'union de la gauche
rien ne nous fera changer il est tout de
même surprenant de constater que les
principaux dirigeants du parti
communiste français sont aujourd'hui
moins conciliants avec leurs partenaires
de gauche que ne le sont les communistes
berlinger et carillo avec leurs
partenaires de droite
là ce qu'on appelle la ligne cunhal au
portugal a peut-être produit
laly soares eh bien je dis tout
simplement que la ligne marché ne fera
pas changer les socialistes et ne
produira pas autre chose que de
maintenir la direction dans laxe où nous
l'avons fixé ensemble en 1972 monsieur
georges marchais le secrétaire général
du parti communiste était il ya quelques
minutes encore l'invité du club de la
presse de 19 heures à 20 heures
monsieur marché a précisé ce soir qu'il
n'avait pas l'intention de changer de
stratégie potez auquel je continue de me
refuser à croix mais enfin dans
l'hypothèse puisque vous vous y placer
et je comprends bien dire
dans l'hypothèse où bhl de parti
socialiste rompre l accord que nous
avons ensemble cela ne changera
absolument rien à ce qu'est la politique
actuelle du parti communiste autrement
dit pour être clair il n'est au pouvoir
de personnes dans ce pays que modifiée
d'un pouce la politique définie au 22e
congrès et par avance messieurs je vous
le dis personne ne le tente d'ailleurs
mais si par hypothèse absurde quelqu'un
tentait de le faire il n'est non pour
pouvoir de personnes à l'extérieur de
nous faire bouger d'un pouce dans la
politique dans la stratégie que nous
avons définies à notre 22e congrès vous
reconnaîtrez qu'une des qualités des
communistes c'est la ténacité
nous voulons cet accord nous voulons que
cette union de la gauche non seulement
soit maintenu et préservé mais qu'elle
soit renforcée et consolidé par la
conclusion d'un bon programme commun de
gouvernement par conséquent pour
aujourd'hui pour demain c'est notre
tâche notre tâche capitale
et croyez moi de toute façon nous ne
renoncerons jamais à notre politique
d'union
bien nous avons vu les déclarations
vigoureuse de georges marchais et de
françois mitterrand alors patrice
duhamel le ton semble assez haut tout de
même quelles sont les perspectives
ce que je pense que l'on peut dire ce
soir c'est que les positions de françois
mitterrand et de georges marchais sont
totalement figée aucun des deux n'a en
réalité changé de position depuis la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi où il y a donc
eu cette quasi rupture à l'intérieur de
la gauche
on est toujours à l'heure du dialogue de
sourds sur l'interprétation même du
programme commun de 1972
en revanche les arrière pensées et les
procès d'intention vous l'avez entendu
se multiplient on peut donc s'interroger
sérieusement ce soir et se demander si
on n'arrive pas dans l'union de la
gauche
au seuil du point de non retour c'est
bien sur l'interrogation qui va dominer
le début de cette semaine à gauche et
l'on attend de connaître maintenant avec
une certaine impatience il faut le dire
les déclarations de françois mitterrand
mercredi au cours d'une conférence de
presse
et puis le soir même et ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas un hasard le soir même
georges marchais il lui présidera une
grande réunion publique à paris donc
deux rendez vous très attendu et
peut-être au bout une quasi certitude
sur l'évolution de l'union de la gauche
demain l'humanité serait une édition
spéciale dont le titre est un appel aux
électeurs et aux électrices comme vous
pouvez le lire
aidez nous pour aboutir à un accord un
autre élément non négligeable dans la
semaine politique qui commence demain le
sondage notre confrère le matin de paris
le matin a fait procéder à 3000
interview ce qui représente un taux de
précision très grand mais je vous
précise que ces interviews ce sondage a
été réalisé avant la cassure de la
gauche le 22 septembre dernier
première question considérez vous que la
participation du parti communiste
gouvernement serait une excellente chose
86 % des électeurs communistes répondu
oui mais 34% seulement des électeurs
socialistes et 20% des radicaux de
gauche ou du moins des électeurs qui
votent pour le parti socialiste ou pour
les radicaux de gauche se déclarent
favorables à la participation des
communistes au gouvernement
autre question extrêmement importante
posées par le matin dont voici la une
que vous découvrirez demain dans vos
kiosques à qui faites-vous confiance
parmi les leaders politiques
on constate que le président valéry
giscard d'estaing arrive très largement
en tête avec 61
1% des personnes interrogées qui
déclarent faire confiance au président
de la république françois mitterrand
obtient 48% talonné par raymond barre
avec 46% et à égalité robert fabre et
jacques chirac avec 33% des personnes
interrogées qui déclarent leur faire
confiance
georges marchais le secrétaire général
du parti communiste recueille 26% des
opinions confiante à son égard nous
l'avons appris peu de temps avant ce
journal
madame lucie fort les pousses du
président de l'assemblée nationale est
décédé aujourd'hui dans sa propriété de
bois sizzla bertrand en seine-et-marne
madame lucie fort a été victime d'une
crise cardiaque
je crois qu'il faut rappeler qui était
madame lucie fort jacques est belle oui
connu estimé que ce soit dans les
milieux politiques littéraires ou
journalistiques lucie fort était âgé de
69 ans lucie fort que l'on voyait
presque toujours aux côtés de son mari
lequel prenait souvent son avis est
prêté beaucoup d'attention à ces
réactions
lucie fort et est l'auteur de nombreux
ouvrages les patients indécise l'autre
personne le malheur foulée bon enfant ou
encore marc diallo les pousses du
président l'assemblée nationale et est
également directrice et fondatrice de la
revue la nef qui traitent régulièrement
de problèmes de société lucie fort en
tout cas les sera pour les journalistes
qui l'ont connu l'image de la discrétion
de la courtoisie mais aussi celle de la
passion et de la bonne humeur
air france et air inter les deux
compagnies nationales françaises
vont-elles réussir à se rapprocher pour
des raisons d'économie et d'efficacité
comme l'avait souhaité monsieur raymond
barre lors du récent salon du bourget
c'est en principe dans trois jours le 28
septembre qu'air france est un terreau
mettront leurs conclusions
or après trois mois de travail intensif
les experts des deux compagnies sont
loin d'être parvenu à un accord
comme nous le révèle notre spécialiste
jean pierre qui tarde
s'il ya un rapprochement air france air
inter il ne sera pas le fait des deux
compagnies
une décision du gouvernement car les
deux transporteurs n'ont pas la même
conception sur leur future collaboration
air france et air inter sont d'accord
sur deux points l'achat du futur
moyen-courrier des années 80 la 200
construit par l'aérospatiale et qui sera
proposé en deux versions 130 et 170
places et le développement de leurs
flottes airbus pour qu'il y ait 24
appareils de ce type en service d'ici
trois ans en revanche les experts n'ont
pas trouvé de solution au problème
roissy orly air france veut qu air inter
s'implante davantage à roissy pour ne
pas perdre dit elle les passagers
arrivant orly ouest et qui préfèrent
continuer leur route sur des compagnies
étrangères basées sur le même aéroport
plutôt que d'aller à roissy air inter
répond qu'elle veut bien augmenter
certaines fréquences sur roissy charles
de gaulle mais la compagnie intérieure
ne veut pas déménager d'orly d'autant
qu'elle vient de regrouper tous ses
services à proximité de l'aéroport
autre point de désaccord le troc des dix
mercure d'air inter contre des caravelle
d'air france c'est un transfert qui
coûtera très cher
il faudra en effet transformé les
appareils aménagements première classe
sur le mercure et atterrissages tout
temps sur la caravelle et surtout former
des équipes 1 même son de cloche
discordant sur la desserte de la corse
les lignes continent corse se sont déjà
déficitaire et comme le gouvernement
voudrait davantage de fréquences qui
paiera ce nouveau déficit bref c'est
encore au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités et de dire maintenant ce
qu'il veut rapprochement ou fusion
quelle que soit la solution adoptée à ne
satisfera ni les deux compagnies ni les
contribuables qui devront payer ce
mariage forcé préconisée par le premier
ministre au mois de juin pour des
raisons d'économie et surtout pour
donner un débouché à nos propres
productions aéronautique
monsieur claude labbé le président du
groupe rpr à l'assemblée nationale a
analysé les perspectives de concorde
aujourd'hui la france ne peut accepter
sans réagir l'échec de ses efforts pour
vaincre la scandaleuse opposition du
gouvernement des états unis à concorde
monsieur claude labbé qui est également
rapporteur du budget de l'aéronautique
civile a ajouté ce qui est très clair
c'est la volonté des américains de nous
imposer l'arrêt de la construction de
concorde à 16 unités plus de 20000
mutilés du travail étaient rassemblées
aujourd'hui aux sables d'olonne à
l'occasion du 33e congrès
leur fédération à cette occasion les
mutilés du travail ont souligné leur
volonté de ne pas être les oubliés de la
société
notre confrère noël bâillon fondateur et
président de l'association nationale des
journalistes d'information médicale est
décédé ce week-end à l'hôpital cochin de
paris
noël buy ont entonné la chronique
médical de plusieurs revues et journaux
et notamment de valeurs actuelles et de
l'aurore le pape paul vi à l'occasion de
son 80e anniversaire qu'il fêtera demain
à évoquer la mort qui s'approche le
saint-père s'est adressé ce matin à 60
mille fidèles rassemblés place
saint-pierre
c'est la seconde fois en cinq semaines
que paul 6 fait allusion à sa mort mais
tous ceux qui ont eu l'occasion
d'approcher pool6 récemment et notamment
monseigneur marty ont trouvé le
saint-père en assez bonne santé
allemagne fédérale un nouveau signe de
vie a été donnée par monsieur meyer le
patron des patrons de rfa l'état major
de crise est immédiatement réunis ce
matin à bonn dans le plus grand secret
le gouvernement israélien a accepté
aujourd'hui la proposition américaine de
reprendre la conférence de genève avec
une délégation arabe unis les israéliens
ont fait savoir que des membres de l'ol
paie c'est à dire des représentants des
palestiniens pourrait participer côté
arabe aux conversations de paix mais à
la condition que ses représentants de
l'ol paie soit peu connu
à jérusalem on affirme qu'israël ne
vérifiera pas de trop près les identités
en attendant sur le terrain la situation
reste très tendue dans le sud liban où
de violents duels d'artillerie ont
continué ce dimanche entre palestiniens
et forces libanaises conservatrice
soutenue par les israéliens
le chef de l'état major adjoint de
l'armée populaire chinoise a révélé à
monsieur raymond barre que la chine
allait faire appel à des pays amis pour
moderniser son armée
c'est la première fois qu'un officier de
haut rang chinois expriment les besoins
de son pays en matière militaire
la france serait considérée par la chine
comme la de ses éventuels fournisseurs
les chinois seraient notamment
intéressés par des missiles anti chars
des missiles anti aériens des chars et
même peut-être des avions à la sncf sur
le réseau sud-est la direction indique
que 75 % du trafic sera assuré demain
lundi la situation redeviendra normale
dans la matinée de mardi seulement
les français dépensent
20 % de leur budget pour leur logement
en revanche seuls 2% des revenus sont
consacrés aux meubles c'est à dire deux
fois moins que pour le budget voiture
pourtant le cadre de vie fait partie de
la qualité d'existence comment améliorer
notre décor quotidien
c'est ce que propose l'exposition
habiter c'est vivre qui se déroule
jusqu'au 9 octobre au grand palais
claude merci mon petit à petit en main
par ci un homme part à je ne voulais pas
d horreur je ne voulais pas tellement
bretez on a manqué de d'une table ou
d'un buffet pendant quelques temps on
l'achetait plus tard se meubler petit à
petit pour beaucoup de familles aux
revenus modestes c'est en effet souvent
la seule solution vous avec des meubles
bon marché généralement disparates
il est difficile d'organiser un cadre de
vie agréable
c'est pour répondre à ces préoccupations
que l'exposition du grand palais propose
des exemples d'équipements mobiliers
adaptés au logement hlm
voici à l'intérieur de f4 ou kenneth p
bibliothèque coin repas chambre à
coucher les meubles sont harmonieusement
disposés en fonction de la dimension des
pièces leur fabrication en grande série
permet d'obtenir le meilleur rapport
qualité prix pour un f4 par exemple le
mobilier complet ne dépasse pas 20 mille
francs
en variant les coloris la disposition
des meubles les concepteurs proposent
une gamme étendue de cadre de vie
différents avec le même type d'éléments
le problème de l'uniformité il n'est pas
question d'imposer ce mobilier il n'est
pas question de dire dans une tour tout
le monde va être meublé la même manière
mais que l'on donne un choix parmi un
catalogue un certain nombre de types de
mobiliers da sa trempe de finition même
avec ces cinq programmes qui sont là et
le nombre de finitions ou le nombre de
coloris on arrive à plus de 60
propositions différentes mais il ne
s'agit absolument pas d'imposer ce
mobilier les pouvoirs publics étudierait
actuellement la possibilité d'encourager
une telle formule par la mise en place
de crédits plus long probablement sur
cinq ans avec des taux d'intérêt plus
faibles que ceux qui sont accordées par
les revendeurs quant aux industriels du
meuble il pourrait envisager dans
l'avenir de fournir directement les
offices hlm habiter c'est vivre mais
jouer au tiercé c'est espérer l'on dit
que l'espoir fait vivre leur léon
zitrone ce tiercé dominical at il été
emballants emballant écouter on s'est
surtout occupé de la victoire de fard ni
dans le prix du moulin de longchamp et
de la victoire 2000 satin qui porte les
couleurs quasi confrères enfin l'un des
patrons d'europe numéro un monsieur jean
luc lagardère alors m'applaudit très
fort controversé dont nous avons voir
les images
eh bien il n'a pas été emballant pour
répondre à votre question
en effet la gagnante il c'est une cause
de police n'y avait que des femelles
la gagnante la remporté de toute une
distance était monté par philippe on est
né
entraîné par john kennington junior et
il y avait à l'arrivée deux grandes
longueurs handicap gagné très facilement
la deuxième place et 20 prises par
rennes delorme et dont il ya eu un vrai
de même une très belle lutte pour la
troisième place qui est revenue à prix
daniel schneider ce qui a fait 85 et as
comme bus des tur fils avec des rapports
qui s'inscrivent sur votre écran
si vous l'avez jouer ce n'est pas trop
mal payé pourquoi fonij présent indiqué
dans ce rapport on peut les données léon
zitrone 2008 159 francs dans l'ordre et
pour cinq francs j'imagine oui puisque
c'est un millier dans un ordre différent
406 francs nous voilà absolument
d'accord pour une fois merci landais 30
et comme chaque dimanche depuis la
rentrée vous avez pu suivre la totalité
des résultats sportifs dans les missions
du service des sports de tf1 cet après
midi à partir de 17h mais avec georges
dominique l'essentiel des résultats et
les images qu'il faut retenir de cette
journée sportive
oui tout d'abord jean claude de
championnat de france de rugby c'était
la deuxième journée du championnat et on
peut dire que bézy a démarré s'est
enflammée d'entrée puisque dimanche
denier béziers a passé 84 points et ce
dernier week-end 77
l'actualité est également deux épreuves
cyclistes ainsi août mail qu'a remporté
tour versailles alors que les belles de
leur côté se sont imposés dans le tour
de l'avenir
l'actualité encore c'était par exemple
dénouement des championnats du monde
elle qui est rude haltérophiles tout de
suite des images mais nous aborderons
auparavant une brève parenthèse pour
signaler que l'actualité sportive s'est
surtout distingué cette semaine par deux
faits disons plutôt extra sportifs
d'abord bien sûr la disqualification de
manchester
à ce propos saint-etienne sera fixé
demain sur son sort un jury d'appel se
réunira ensuite dans un lieu tenu vous
bien tenu secret on sait que manchester
a préparé disons un volumineux dossier
pour sa défense
alors les anglais repêchés ou pas
personne ce soir 10 on est en mesure
d'apporter un élément de réponse
l'autre fait de la semaine vous l'avez
deviné c'est la guéguerre du tennis avec
l'avènement de cette fameuse raquette à
double cordage qui donne en quelque
sorte des effets imprévus à la balle
tous les joueurs ont ils adopté ou la
raquette miracle sera t-elle interdite
on ne saura rien en fait avant le 1er
octobre et la réunion de la fédération
internationale tout de suite cependant
regagnant la coupe aurait deux thèmes
semaine ici qui évolue qui emploie une
raquette traditionnel de dos et
guillermo vilas et de face patrick
proisy
c'est la suite de la demi finale
interrompue hier à cause de la pluie et
c'est la balle de match 3 y regarder va
monter et vilas trouver l'ouverture
victoire de l'argentin en cinq sets et
demain en finale vilas résistera sans
doute à la raquette miracle du français
va cela après la terre battue la piste
de versailles où se mêlent que le
coureur à la casquette est troisième
mais il va passer en tête devant cuyper
et le belge de moins c'est le final de
tours versailles l'ex paris cu premier
l'hollandais de paris soutenait qu
deuxième de moins qu'au troisième
eni qui perd l'autre et hollandais le
peloton avec roger de vlaeminck arrivera
une minute plus tard sur les routes du
tour de l'avenir les belges ont presque
tout raflé maillot jaune dernière étape
est entre autres le classement par
équipes le maillot jaune est resté
finalement sur les épaules de ce garçon
est dit shepers scheper déjà champion de
belgique cette saison c'est la première
fois en 15 ans qu'un belge inscrit son
nom au palmarès de l'épreuve
quant au premier français il s'appelle
baudier il termine septième
alexeïev se porte toujours bien lui il
vient des pôles et 245 kg c'est réussi
pour la moitié du mouvement l'autre
moitié réussie également le jeter
vassili alexeyev reste donc nous sommes
le plus fort du monde
l'haltérophilie comme les autres sports
ne fait pas de ségrégation elle ne peut
pas refuser les gros bébé assimilée ici
à la catégorie des super lourds
mais attention stuttgart et ces
championnats du monde nous ont prouvé qu
alexeyev ne représentait pas l'image de
marque des poids et haltères peut même
quel bel homme la météo de votre lundi
demain il y aura des brouillards puis
quelques pluies dans l'extrême nord-est
mais demain après midi le temps
deviendra doux et ensoleillé sur presque
toute la france je vous rappelle une
ultime fois que nous vivons depuis ce
matin à l'heure d'hiver et je vous
suggère de vérifier que vos montres mais
aussi et surtout votre réveil matin
indique bien qu'il est 20h31 et 38
secondes
sinon vous partir au travail une heure
trop tôt demain matin et vous ne pourrez
pas nous le reprocher vers 23 heures
c'est un à chaillot qui vous présentera
le dernier journal n'oubliez pas
également le rendez vous du service
politique de tf1 pour une analyse
détaillée des élections sénatoriales
aujourd'hui juste après le film dans ce
splendide décor permettez moi de vous
souhaiter une excellente soirée
au nom de tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à
préparer ce journal bonsoir